donc j'ai une autre projection demain
tu t'en fiches le
mien est toujours ailleurs et
toi Arthur mon article ouais c'est un
article fantastique peux tu le lire pourriture
non elle ne lit pas bien mon travail tu
penses que c'est juste que ta femme fasse tout
le  soulever des charges lourdes pour que vous puissiez faire semblant d'
être un intellectuel
je vous vois faire du shopping au bar je suis une
femme adulte qui n'appelle pas chérie comment le
soi-disant alcoolique quelqu'un qui paie l'
hypothèque j'ai fini d'essayer de faire amende honorable
avec vous bien je suis  nous ne pouvons pas continuer à faire
cela
l'IRM a détecté un petit homme à quel point
la chirurgie est risquée
c'est une procédure hautement invasive puis-je
mourir en le faisant il est possible que vous croyiez que
je suis parti je suis scientifique Dieu est plus notre création
et nous sommes à lui si Dieu ne l'est pas
je t'attends de l'autre côté s'il te plait il
y a des années j'ai eu une liaison
je lui ai donné une raison de boire comme excuse
pour boire merci je vais le Custis ici
c'est pendant nos moments les plus sombres mais les mal-
aimés sont les plus proches je veux mourir après
chambres vides si froides entourées de personnes  ple
ne sont là que parce que c'est leur travail d'
être
quelle est votre couleur préférée, nous saurons
ma couleur préférée c'est bien
comment ce
moment qui change la vie tombe que je frappe un peu de
Floride - était vraiment important
et tout sur terre
vous